I
alright so let's get started let's
welcome Felix Philip and sinker from
blue yonder they will talk about
expiratory time series analysis of the
New York City Subway data so welcome and
offered yeah hi and thank you all for
coming so we thought we basically walk
you through a time series analysis
problem and along the way explain some
of the concepts that that matter in this
case because it's not quite your regular
machine learning problem there are some
special properties and approaches
specific to time series why can we talk
about this because this is something
that we do kind of regularly in our in
our daily work so we work at blue your
honor by the way we have a little social
event tonight if you want to participate
we have a booth downstairs just meet us
there yeah just wanted to mention that
the idea is that in this tutorial you
get exposed to some of the concepts that
matter in time series analysis but to
show you some of the challenges you face
when you do that and how we approach
those tasks which is not the only way to
solve it most importantly get you to
dive into an example problem and do your
own experimentation and yeah maybe learn
something along the way so we'll try to
explain stuff if you have a question
don't hesitate to to raise your hand
there are three of us there's always one
can rush to you and answer any question
if you get stuck or anything but also
don't worry if you get stuck if if there
is any kind of an immediate result that
we develop that you need for a later
step we actually provide all those
intermediate results if you kind of
follow the tracks then we have the
intermediate data also
in a sample data set so that said let's
make sure you all have the required
Python modules and the sample data so I
listed here the packages that you need
the simplest way to get this all
installed is if you have conned already
just cloned the github repository we
have requirements files it can just use
to install all the packages so if you
start by by cloning that you'll find the
requirements files and the sample data
that we use and I pies and notebooks
that we use and if you have any kind of
problem doing that just wave raise your
hands and we'll help
and if that doesn't work it's just the
packages that I understood there it
should be there if it's not then you can
just install the packages by their name
just call now install numpy side pie
psychic learning pandas and ipython
notebook and if you do that you should
be able to to start and I pass in the
book
so most of these packages are well-known
we're using one package that was
developed at a company that we open
source that's the pi d SE package and
right now it's tagged with a slightly
unusual pre-release version string
that's why you have to get this extra
option when you pip install it and
that's only on pi PI so there's no Conda
package for that yet so we also are
going to need the PI DIC
does that work for everybody okay okay
somebody anybody get getting stuck or we
just continue okay cool so now let's
look at the task with the proud owners
of these of this little food car and
it's our home spot is a subway station
exit and well this is not just a funny
story to have a background for for what
we're doing it will actually influence
our solution as you will see later on so
this is not an academic exercise but it
will actually influence our solution in
the end so we're selling pretzels in the
street and every day we have to decide
how many pretzels we buy for the next
day so we have to kind of make sure we
don't buy too many and we don't buy too
few ideally we buy the exact amount that
we're going to sell the next day we can
use basically our experiences from the
past to make a prediction how many
people are going to to buy something on
the next day so the good thing is that
we have really nice data to do this we
will use the data from the subway
station turn styles that the New York
City MTA is collecting so they are
actually really nice and provide data I
think they're just starting to provided
through an API when we got the data was
still a download basically what it is
it's the enter and exit counts of the
turnstiles at every station aggregated
over four hours
and you can actually get the history of
the past several years and this is what
we'll be working with and now I hand
over to my colleague to take you yeah to
to have a first look at the data
you notice your pumpkin covered in soft
I need one
come at least so everyone can read so
before we start diving into our data I
just want to go the raw data and show
how we refine it and aggregated to our
problem to use it for our problem so we
have some more time to do more as a
model developments yes okay so i hope
everyone has downloaded the files from
the repository so we start with
importing packages and loading the data
into a pandas dataframe so first we've
gotta look at at the head of the data so
get a feeling what's in it so actual the
download load the data from the MTA has
more information so it has information
about see notes at which the stations
are connected to but here I already
refined it to timestamp number of
entries number of exits and the station
name so we are talking about the station
Fulton Street the data starts at the
23rd of may 2010 and we receive we've
got 686 increase in the time interval
between day before four hours until
midnight and 751 exits arm yeah so in
scrolling down so if we want if we
brought
time series okay we see oh what's that
we've got some spikes at really two
million exits or entries at all times
that's really really bad so it seems
we've got a data problem ok so we
replace those implausible values no no
one has millions of exits at interval of
four hours and we're putting in another
number so let's do that okay and plot
again oh you've got a time series we've
got about 5,000 to 24,000 exits we are
just looking at XS in our exercise just
for simplification so our time series
goes from june from end of may 2010
until end of 2013 and later on with
devices time series in an ensample auto
sample part for mortal testing I talk
about that later later on so don't pick
so now we are checking this time series
for gaps ok zoom time by you counts well
we've got some we expect for hours
intervals in this data but we also have
eight and 16 hours intervals so I looked
into the data and every Saturday
interval Saturday morning is missing in
the data I don't know why and we have to
deal with it because we want we want a
time series without gaps so here you see
there's a gap between eight o'clock and
the evening in four o'clock in the morn
there should be a midnight data data set
so what can we do for example we can
interpolate it the linear function
pandas provides this so we interpolate
every look again at the time season and
you can see we've got now a value for
midnight which is 2060 plus 189 / tube
so very simple but for our purpose it's
just enough then we aggregated to a
daily time series we want to have some
number of exits per day and we add some
columns we need later on like year month
day and weekday weekday so counter
between 0 & 6 Monday zeros on sunday is
6 so put it in and as I mentioned before
we define in a non sample bio flag and
we set it on 2013 say whole year is our
outer sample test data and the training
data is just the time series between
2010 and 2012 and then we'll save it so
so just wanted to show you so we
prepared this notebook to show you that
no data is perfect and you have always
to manipulate the data to model it later
on depends depending on your purpose so
just going to show you slide back to the
slides Phoenix which one who's in
student certain volume
okay so with the data source now we are
talking about the model so the next
notebook will be interactive I want to
invite invite you to browse through this
aggregated data and make some plots so
if if you go to the notebooks and go to
the tutorials to the second notebook you
want to start after I explain you what I
what a framework for the model we want
to use as I mentioned before we've got
an ensample an auto sample data flac we
want to use it in all our model
comparisons later on we are talking
about Horace horizon one so in the
example we've got some data and we've
got here the truth and we want to
predict in the morning of the false may
the number of exit sis day so for
example if we calculate a rolling mean
which is just mean sweetie with a mean
of sorts numbers are it's resolved 1067
is a prediction from yesterday we use
amusing cas using a data in history and
so you see it shifted and it's not a
good estimate for 6200 so as you can see
it's just an example that you have to
shift it a turn looking for for
comparison between cues cruising
prediction for comparison we chose the
mean average I mean absolute error which
is defined on the next slide it is just
the absolute deviation between Cruz and
prediction divided by the number of
events so I want you now to go to the
message it's so to the data exploration
part this is its tutorial own nature
energy emission is nice it this is not a
true story okay so I want to start what
you to start the first two parts so just
loads packages and the data and Jen we
look okay what do we have we've got the
exits per day aggregated the year month
day and week the in the sample how much
time okay so I want you the next five
minutes to just to some plots ask us
questions what you see and we've got
some suggestions put down plot time
since we profile Mons profile just play
around with the data just block for
example because a weekday and numbers
all of exit everything over the example
or crumble or combined time so the plot
of the average for every Monday for
every Tuesday for every wednesday and so
on so what's common to every Monday
common to every tuesday the the
prototypical week
if you're annoyed by the matplotlib
windows popping up there's anybody not
know how to activate in line plots and
so again it's % mad fat lip in line yeah
and then you got the plots in the
notebook yeah
speaking to tested building was present
when citing souls on Phyllis I put it
hasn't all stippling my dog transmission
doesn't anymore okay yeah i just seen in
this photo friend from scottish you know
she cannot have
it's not
is that on the time it is not be in
business acquaintance hey no I don't
damn time who is the hot damn on limit
no it's not yes I need lettuce wonderful
dog as soon as my nike no Felix who is
this the slide but [ __ ] signing off
keep control a daughter so 4 goes to
miss the first slide so everything you
need is in one github repository ohh if
you throw this new world people get the
data notebooks that we could help and
refine the files into it so on what we
do
I calm down it just
you
so I was no suggest that i would like to
invite you two can play a little around
with the data for yourself we have
listed a few ideas here in this notebook
and giving you a few links to the
relevant under structions
that's actually something that's really
typical for statistical modeling is
starting with a really trivial model
first because in many many cases you
have nothing to compare your fancy shiny
model too so you need a reference all
the time and then you almost all the
time start with a really trivial model
basically as the baseline to compare
yourself to so this is not just the just
to to to mess with you to make you work
more but this is actually a very
standard practice you you have like the
simplest model that you could think of
and that's the first one that you
implement and then you go and implement
the next one and then you can see the
differences and see what you actually
achieved by using fancy machine learning
techniques and it's sometimes humbling
a thousand times yes appointed time to
the food sales or that connect with the
head with the money
there are by to us the opportunity to do
individual differences
perfect
should so move on so again let me just
walk you through why we solve this
problem here sperm import the data we
embody the variation function so this is
again the trivial models so then we
basically define a function that
calculates a rolling mean it slow moving
exponentially weighted average and a
fast-moving exponentially weighted
average and we apply it to the data then
we are interested in moving averages
that take a decode just the same weekend
so for as a prediction for ball say
Monday we want to have a moving averages
moving average calculated from all past
monday's so we do this in a group by so
we group the data frame by weekday and
then again apply the function that
calculates the moving averages
so the last step here this is this line
we have to shift everything by seven
days for the weekday averages or by one
day or the normal moving averages just
to make sure that we don't include the
target in cell in the in the prediction
that we reach eating
why is this taking so long doesn't mixer
oh
so then we can using this very good
function that we just introduced we can
compare these models and see which
performs better than which which
performs best so these explanations were
weighted moving averages are not useful
only as predictions models in themselves
but can also be used as building blocks
for more complex prediction models so
for example we could take a slow moving
average a fast-moving Everett or a
moving averages with different time
constants and then use them as input for
regression models say linear regression
or any non did you have a question that
you like reading is for example so this
is what we did here in the third
notebook so but since we are running out
of time I would suggest that we skip
this one just have a look at it yourself
if you like to and we go on with
multiplicative models and our models
oh just earn to specify the ARMA model
so we are using a package from our comp
which flow can with him from our company
designed it's called pi d e and it's a
little bit easier to use than the stats
model armor and just for your
information I put in two links if you
want to know more about the ARMA model
and arima models and seasonal ARMA
models which I cannot explain in detail
in succession just click at the links i
think this is a quite nice explanation
on siblings just try it out so just in
brief we've got an armor model armor
stands for outer regressive moving
average and n and m other orders of
those models so it's composed of a noise
term epsilon the arm up as an auto
regression term which just defines in
first order for example you know
something happens yesterday and it has
an inference to today or and so on and
you're moving average you just head is
the epsilon and the B is just no
coefficient so if you want to model with
AMA you have to look at the partial auto
correlation functions and the
autocorrelation function plots so in the
very simple example if something depends
on yesterday and yesterday pens in the
day before and so on usually you've got
an ACF plot which is slowly degrading
you've got a peek at zero which is one
as usual per definition then the second
maximum is at one end it degrades and if
you look at the partial autocorrelation
and if you take out all tech relations
in between
you've got a peek at one because
everything is explained with the first
lack of time shift so just as a reminder
okay let's go to the notebooks so before
we start with with armor I have to
explain armor is not very good with
non-stationary cases so in our example
if you had a glimpse at sea a yearly
dependence of the data so we've got a
strong trend so at 2010 we've got 12,000
exits and 2011 more I'm 2013 merely 25
26 hours and exits so at first you have
to remove the linear trend just do an
ordinary least square fit move the trend
again the simple ARMA model we are
talking about is not very good with
seasonal effects and we know okay with a
strong seasonal component some months in
winter we've got low numbers and some of
we've got higher numbers and we've also
a week weekly profile which is not very
good for a simple ARMA model so any
ideas is to first remove those friends
just I want to I want you to do that we
show the results later on just / vector
which has which is a dictionary like
first months is a mean of one point
something and so on and do the same with
with a week after you've got room after
you move to Trent I prefer just as an
idea prefer a multiplicative model just
because I don't like negative numbers
and we don't have negative exits just
try try that out try the ARMA model from
PI this is there some documentation
they're just just want to click there
and show you what we've got no
offline okay sorry you have to do it
yourself and you just need the
constructor and it's quite easy to
handle so it's just you've just to
calculate the parameters and it
everything's automatic so don't have to
do a lot so I hope we'll get you you get
there that you've got at least effect
factor model and if you're lucky you you
have got armor a very easy ARMA model
okay at first just within the data and
to remove or grant if you just just
glimpse we're doing a linear regression
fit predict and do a trend removal it's
Martha system
we've got about 15 to 20 20 minutes for
that part with squad shot I'm sorry but
here
so if you're new to pandas and you you
struggle with the notation or the way
things are done you can of course you
can basically just cheat open the
solution notebook and and click your way
through that and go to the more advanced
parts with the actual modeling a son
what we are doing here is just building
in time index just for linear fit and
we're looking at the time difference
from first of January 2010 it's already
done and then we define our in sample
our user time index as X and the
quantity want we want to predict is why
and we import from sk sk learn linear
model and do a linear regression and to
the fit and then we do a prediction and
fill the result into a column in our
data frame and if we plot that it looks
like it's not very good visible it's
just as a green line this is a linear
trend and we want to remove that and for
that purpose just we divide now by the
trend
businesses so that's DEET rendered plot
and you can see okay it's not perfect
we've got still some fluctuation and
discuss the seasonality and we want to
remove so it's part so we still at least
have only it's real time series so okay
we've got the factor model which we
define as Trent times weekday times
months factor we do a group I of the
exits without linear trend and fill it
into a dictionary so we want to remove
the factor we just divide by by this
vector and the dictionary depending on a
weekday we also do that afterwards after
we divided by the weekday and the trend
we divide by the months you can also /
mutate that doesn't matter and at the
end we've got time series with our
linear trend with our weekday and
monthly profile and let's block that
time series so you can see it's small as
a fluctuation around one we've got some
spikes at the end well so not everything
is a plane power bypasses factor model
so and if we want to look how Wells is
very simply factor model / firms it's a
static model because you've got only
coefficient efficient depending on three
vectors you can look at that we define
the model then we do in sample auto
sample the appliances we fill a column
and we import our evaluation function
and then we look okay how good is this
on the training sample while 6,700 is ok
but you see
it's not matching all the fluctuations
it's very static okay and all the sample
it looks like that so it's just the data
from 2013 but it still model to the
monthly dependency and the trend and
also the week with dependencies because
you've got all this up and down pattern
but the mean every I mean absolute error
is not so good 8900 so if you want to
put this into perspective some people
use a relative error so as I / the mean
number of exits in this example so we've
got I don't know it by heart it's about
25,000 so you've got a percentage error
of about nine 227 about Oh points with
resource that is three percent deviation
so it's if you in if you're talking to
your customer mail order and everything
is this quality forecast quality is not
very handy but not very you don't know
what's the number means so 9000 what can
you do with that so it's just / see me
number of exits and you got something
and relative okay so shall I go on with
the ama model with or you want to have
more time it's also by tomorrow so okay
we do the ARMA model on the detrended
and factorized data we define a residual
for input and ok now we load at first a
time ahead some talk about on the slides
about this auto correlation plot as i
explained to
2p per definition at zero and then turn
at the first leg second leg and so on
it's degrading okay and it's the Aero
Bank and if it's below the Arab and
there's no real correlation anymore okay
let's have a look at the partial
autocorrelation if since degrading comes
only from dependency of one leg to each
other and you can see you've got a huge
p gets one so we've got more or less on
60 trended series autoregressive model
of one okay so let's import models
what's the hell know what an unpaid
ok tomorrow
excuse me let's get you smashed open up
okay this morning what if I this a
kidney okay we have to do it with our
plots an actual did so we just import
from PI this is the module mini see and
armor the miniseries it's very handy if
you want to want to if you don't know
what parameters to give to your armor
model you've got the AEC akiyama mention
criteria and the patient's be icy and
this is function as some parameters of
the first one it's for the
autoregressive part if you got an order
of 1 2 3 you can put in this list in
order for the moving averages a warning
it's not very fast because we've got a
lot of combinatorics if you've got a lot
of vector so if you're not sure if
you've got a autoregressive one moving
average one model you can dry out ok 1
comma 2 1 comma 2 and it looks what is
the minimal aec or B EC and then it
calculates our auto regressive legs and
say moving average legs so in our case
we looked at blobs and decided okay
we'll take our progressive model without
moving average part so just our legs is
one if you want to take a moving average
model into account you would put in 1
comma awesome yeah so yeah so we would
put in a 1 comma 1 that would be a arma
1 comma 1 model
okay okay so it should work now yes okay
just I just remove that part and okay
that's the main part now we know our
legs it's just one very simple
autoregressive model we construct our
armor which got some a and B which if
you look at the definition in Wikipedia
and the literature and also to pile easy
definition while the a is for they are
our paths givers the MA pad and got
preferred a random state and then we fix
constants and we estimate parameters
with our data well that's all take some
time and we've got a status report with
different information so very important
okay we've got one parameter the X is
fitted and it's terminated successfully
if you've got more parameters on your
armor model it can be is that it's not
terminating successfully and you've got
a warning here and your model is not
good anyway though okay what do we have
one to do a prediction okay that's on
the daytime before the transformation
we've got a point 22 ok what does it
mean okay we've got answer other part
one point seven so we do it back
transformation of the data into the exit
space and okay we've got an ensample
mean absolute error of 2008 or not 88
that's very good because beforehand we
had bizarre Amorph models and everything
else with about five Sol's and eight
cells and so it's quite good number so
let's go look
it's a out sample okay it's a little bit
worse but we've got a higher number of
exits air zone it's quite nice and
promising model just was the easy
autoregressive part of one so if we zoom
in you can see okay so weakly the
solution looks fine the absolute number
looks okay we've got some here we've got
some at the end of the year we've got
some holidays so that's not a good
holiday model but and the whole it's
very promising so and we want to check
if our new model has any dependencies on
on the legs anymore let's just be
blocked the deviation between the fit
and the truth and okay now auto
correlations anymore that's good what
was the partial autocorrelation oh it's
fine to got no partial autocorrelation
which like one anymore so that's fine so
the last notebook I think we've got the
quarter of an hour we want to talk okay
we've gotten our model we've got a
prediction which at least is usually
it's mean it's okay what can we do with
that so let's look at also lose let's it
last notebook okay so just go through
that at first everything here is a
probability density distribution so we
want ok we are predicting mean but
actually we want to have a distribution
why why don't want to ever do so let's
look at first it's a data and we can see
we've got a histogram and sets all the
exits over all the time well I try to
fit well tried several fits and
right now I chose a gamma function which
has two parameters which can be
translated to mean and variance so if
you want to model a gamma function need
two parameters in your prediction at
least so that's just the true histogram
and it's normed 21 okay so at the
beginning we were talking about selling
pretzels so we have to buy pretzels so
what's the estimator we want to use and
why did we take a linear error quantity
like the mean absolute deviation or
error first we've got a problem you're
buying a your your prediction is too
high or too low its linear because we
want to buy pretzels and it starts the
cost function is directly correlated
it's linear because we want to first
want to weigh every event the same you
could take a quadratic error mean
squared error but then you would take
outliers more on two accounts and send
the other of values and let's see what
we have got the distribution which are
you find peace was and we've got a
linear cost function assume linear cost
function okay not selling one pretzel
one dollar throwing away one pretzel one
dollar so if we are perfect we'd have no
costs okay so just this is blood okay
define it what's it some distribution
not defined ok i am skipped set one
okay I have to go to back to the slides
we've got one slide students to cost
functions so here we've got the
symmetric cost functions as told you
before that's for predictions that
seduced and want to know okay we've got
let's say here we've got the true
distribution of our exits and we say
okay each each one of this axis bias one
pretzel which is not true but at least
it's an estimate and okay we want to
minimize this function so we can reroute
it was a distribution of our forecast in
the notebook i take the troop
contribution act through distribution
because i didn't want to construct the
and probability density okay we
convoluted and that works for every
distribution you can take everything
because of the definition it's one and
if you calculate it if you've got a
linear cost functions the minimum of of
this convolution is always for the best
the best estimate is always in medium so
here's a definition of a quantized oh
it's a point five and a more realistic
example you can have here let's say you
have to support vectors notebook so here
you've got the minima minimum for the
convolution of linear function with same
cost for throwing away and buying a
pretzel so as I sit here
okay so find the minimum minimum is at
16,000 308 and the median of the gamma
distribution is well justjust was
because of the binning of our
convolution so that works and it proves
okay our calculations correct now we are
going to take a different cost function
without selling not selling a losing
customer costs as 2.5 dollar and
throwing away still one euro every one
dollar and okay and we defined cost
function and we convolute and it's not
clearly visible but the minimum is at a
different value if we look at it just
looking for the minimal bin we get the
Connie's into one described if you know
any of the contact an awkward name is
near appleton ah ok our minimum is now
at 25,000 and sets a 71 percent quantile
officer distribution so if you do the
calculation of the formula on the slide
you will get 0 point 7 as a best
estimator for that problem so what do we
learn depending on the problem just
predicting a mean or the medium is not
always the best guess it always depends
on the cost function so if you can't and
we learn all copy for our cost function
is purely symmetric it's like this
absolute function it's always the median
if it's different we have to look for a
best guess like here 71 percent which is
natural it's it if your prediction is
too low you won't sell any pretzels so
if you go to a higher quantile of you
which is a distribution you are your
minimal you have got minimal costs so
always saying OK in the mean mean is for
example we've got I don't know twenty
thousand passengers exits okay i will
say twenty thousand but reality i need
twenty-five thousand forces cost
function people to be at the minimum
questions how about this removed from
action not not really fast and we've got
a customer where we have to do a sublime
chain demand we have to order some goods
every day and if you would use the mean
or see fifty percent quanta would always
have out of stock situation in the in
the locations of the store so it's very
realistic and actual you do a simulation
you've got your prediction you have got
use the process it's a customer and
you've got to take account okay you're
not ordering every day but let's say for
one item every two days another item
every three days and you have to find
the best working point what what's the
prediction and what the prediction do
you take into account and what's the
number of goods you want to buy so it's
very realistic it's just simplified here
the same as long as i'm gonna change
some chances there also have if you've
got the data yes but it's how to build a
model if the station is closed once in a
year you know got three years of data
and it's just one event and if the event
occurs five times a year it's still hard
so
some ok this is we are always dealing
with a problem and our customers are
telling us ok you have to to know it
it's Christmas yes we know it's
Christmas but with just three data
points and Christmas shifts with a
combination of weekdays every seven or
ten years so someone challenged in
addition to model selection would be to
get the data when when they did a
promotion for example and also you have
to get to data but still there's some
interpretation from the customer ok he
sinks this thing you've got the data and
everything's fine but sometimes you're
you're limited by number of events or
still it's it's not it's a purely noise
and you've got you've got sometimes you
have to say okay that's single event and
you know the correlation but you cannot
derive a prediction from that okay thank
you what I come not not in this case
this is no this just connect for
certification that passers-by equals
sales because then I think that you
could almost say this may be a constant
factor well maybe not David as
absolutely yes this is something you
would maybe if you make the next
iteration of the model you would you
would look at ya as you said holidays
weekends and things like this and Mulder
not explicitly actually wondered you
have to take into account okay those are
more working people let's say
businessmen going there or more children
if they are children would sell ice
cream and if it's don't know it depends
on what what you want to know and what
do you know about about the situation of
such stations oh it's in that model it's
just simplified it's just an idea what
can you do with the data okay we want to
save red cells hot dogs and the New York
subway has a lot of station so you would
you have got a lot of data I would ever
ever year okay sis stations you would
put a back in there in some on the other
one and winter on weekdays and we could
just imagine there's a huge space of
possibilities that's a that's a cool
thing actually about the data set you
get these four hour intervals for every
station for several years and there's in
the data is even there are markers for
on which line station is so you could
maybe start trying to to separate the
influence of the different lines and you
know okay some people exited the station
before how many people exited souther
stations sometime like them after that
so okay it's not fine enough but if it's
the station's sounds the same line yeah
and if you so the the ARMA model maybe
was a little bit much in terms of
science the author of the the python
module is actually in the rooms in the
last row so give questions about that
when to use it how it was done things
like that just
walk up to him and asking all right
thank you so much for attending yeah
you
you